this comes from Scott from Winnipeg
Canada Scott are you here from Winnipeg
oh yeah a peg welcome well oldest
[ __ ] place on earth yeah I was there
February once February Winnipeg Koller
oh man witch's tit as they say which I'm
like how can you prove that
ever thought of witches to rock several
times and Chile or no Luke lukewarm I'd
say not really cold that hot yeah I
literally used to [ __ ] a witch
she was a hardcore Wiccan yeah yeah and
you were [ __ ] a witness I was indeed
and she used to spend a majority of her
time travelling around in a van
following the Grateful Dead selling
falafels I'm sorry it's still back up
you were [ __ ] a Wiccan I was really
and she was a witch she was a maid
philosoph falafels flosses falafels
she made falafels in a van and sold him
in the parking lot that's how she made
her income really yeah she was quite the
catch I don't know I didn't Marian that
girl she had it all why did she have to
make the falafels couldn't you just
conjure them I don't think it actually
works that way really yeah she would
just make levels a big cauldron outside
her van but she wore a bag around her
neck filled with magic [ __ ] not exactly
sure what it was but she always had to
have this bag around her neck cuz that
was her talisman did it have like pink
hearts yellow moons orange stars she
wasn't a leprechaun she was a witch I
used to wear cereal around my neck as
well but not because I was a witch just
cuz you know the pouch full of magic
beans or something and and she would
always have to have even during sex she
had to have it on it was like her
strength or something really very
strange way to say so weren't you afraid
to break up with a witch I'd be
terrified she'd be like oh no rau
well she went off to follow the dead one
day and I moved change the phone number
everything so I was cool Scott from
Winnipeg writes I forgot we were doing a
show here my wife and I are on our first
trip to LA from Winnipeg she used to say
that all the time there's a monkey with
wings sitting on the bed it was very
disturbing you [ __ ] she'd be like I'm
melting never gave her a facial kiss of
death Scott from Winnipeg writes the
winch dude I mean I gotta call you like
hairy porker or something like that
[Music]
quite the checkered past we decide which
house was she like Gryffindor Hufflepuff
Slytherin up the big tree slower and I'm
pretty sure she was delivery she was
nasty yeah Scott from Winnipeg right
we've decided to spend our last evening
in Los Angeles with you guys at HBO oh
that's very sweet thank you very much
guys been a lawyer and loyal listener
suck it - man not in January a dope
Eggers hey welcome man welcome the
coolest place I've ever been
cold is the witch's tit man the cold is
a witch's tit route
yeah called Winnipeggers Manor from
Winnipeg beggars peg lingers that's what
I call we don't call us that at all sir
we'll be leaving now
coz pegging means a completely different
thing in my lexicon oh yeah the beggars
you know Hagar's is a chick puts on a
strap-on fun - dude that's correct why
are you saying your
in the world of the people who have
[ __ ] witches sexually expensive which
never pegged me No
well the wand slipped up there one who's
an axe I'm gonna [ __ ] you with my
witch's nose Ralph now bend over stuff
the poison apple up there was very
uncomfortable I've been loyal listeners
this episode one I recently got my wife
Jennifer listening in preparation for
our trip rather than have ralph act like
a performing monkey for our shut up can
I request that Kevin welcome Jennifer to
HBO using his phone sex voice aka the
dirty van driving ass eating pervert
character how does my voice go you know
we did that phone sex bit that one time
and you were all creepy just don't go
down yeah do it that way let's go to my
directions [ __ ] creepy welcome
[Music]
just like the facedown yeah lost your
butt with my tongue all right that's
enough welcome welcome welcome welcome
I don't remember my agency boys that was
it that was it well I wouldn't call the
sexy voice but it was completed before
[Music]
you
[Music]